quelle est la différence entre une
simple lectrice de jane austen ouais
c'est encore pire que ce que je croyais
et une véritable fanatique les ouvrages
de la romancière qu'elle n'a cessé de
relire ou encore sa passion dévorante
pour monsieur d'arcins tentive arrêter
le meilleur moment complètement barjo
il traverse l'océan pour venir jusqu'ici
est plongée dans l'univers de jane aussi
une parenthèse aussi vous allez au
château d'ars si oui je connais les
trois premiers chapitres d'orgueil et
préjugés depuis que j'ai 13 ans c'est
quoi dans la vie
bienvenue dans l'angleterre de la
régence belle brochette
j'attends de mes invités qu'elle bat
nice tout ce qui se rapporte à notre
époque moderne une jeune femme permettez
moi de vous présenter miss china first
oil une orpheline sans le sou vent vous
avez pris la formule basique simple
privilège 7 dans l'alvéolé stx effrayant
comme endroit si j'étais betsch
gaspiller tout mon argent à la recherche
d'aînés dire las il ressemble messieurs
car il y à un bal m'a-t-on dit le
dernier soir
est ce que vous aimez douce et ne tient
pas vous n'avez jamais été heureuse en
amour je suis célibataire parce que de
toute évidence les hommes sont des
créatures fictives
qu'est ce que vous pensez de jenna
l'étape cruciale suis une vraie
catastrophe schiste
désormais je prends en charge ma
destinée une héroïne de tennis tennis se
fiance toujours à la fin alors moi aussi
je vais me lancer
moi je suis fou de toi si tu voulais
bien bossé chardy 6 meilleurs sites web
coup de foudre à austin landes